so let's now talk about the propaganda
war and the just obvious lies that are
being told around the death of Jamaal
khashoggi a Washington Post journalist
at the Saudi embassy in Istanbul Turkey
if you thought that Kellyanne Conway or
Sarah Huckabee Sanders or Stephen Miller
or whoever were good at what I call
shameless spin I want to introduce you
to Adel al-jubeir who is a diplomat
who's been the Saudi Minister of Foreign
Affairs since 2015 he's only the second
person not belonging to the House of
Saud to hold the office he was educated
in the United States he holds an
honorary doctorate in Humane Letters
from the University of North Texas and
he is an utter and total shill he was
interviewed on Fox News by Bret Baier
exclusive interview huge news amazing
we're finally going to figure out what
it is that happened to Jamal khashoggi I
have only about a minute of video here
and we have to break it down into like
three or four parts we almost need to
break it down line by line because this
guy is such a blatant lying shill that
if you don't look at it line by line
really crazy stuff will just slip by you
okay interview of the foreign minister
of foreign affairs minister on Fox News
let's go to clip number one you're an
authoritarian government you're saying
that the Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman did not know about this at all
even though there are members of this
15-person team that are closely aligned
with him
Oh Britta first of all we're not an
authoritarian government we're a
monarchy we have our checks and balances
we have our systems we aren't an
authoritarian government we're a
monarchy that's right there's no
difference between Saudi Arabia and
England it's the exact same thing it's
just a bar keypad why are the bar people
being so critical it's like that it's
like us saying we're not a show we're a
program this is a pro nonnamous it's
exactly right it is these weird semantic
distortions and if you look at the
definition of an authoritarian
government favoring or enforcing strict
obedience to Authority they've got that
the bad Authority coming at the expense
of personal freedom they've got that
autocratic systems of government and
decision-making despotic and tyrannical
draconian oppressive when it comes to
all sorts of different groups of people
we're already in fantasy land just at
this number one thing but Bret Baier
this guy's actually pretty good he
clearly has some pretty good media
trading Brett Bay or unable to sort of
interrupt and interject and he continues
with the delusions the individuals who
did this outside the scope of authority
there obviously was a tremendous mistake
made and what compounded the mistake was
the attempt to try to cover up that is
unacceptable in the government these
things unfortunately happen first of all
it's not true that it's unacceptable in
any government Saudi Arabia has been
doing this stuff for a while it's
acceptable in other governments North
Korea comes to mind but the key line
there is these things unfortunately do
happen no they don't
in most governments these things don't
happen this is an attempt to normalize
the kidnapping torture and dismemberment
of journalists who write in favor of
reforms don't always happen you ought to
watch out for the passive voice - these
things happen it doesn't you know make
you look into who is actually
responsible for making it happen an
unfortunate event took place mistakes
were made let's go to the next clip and
it's just digging deeper and deeper and
deeper you want to make sure that those
who are responsible are punished and we
want to make sure that we have
procedures in place
from happening again our history as
Saudi Arabia for the past 18 years 80
plus years since the founding of the
modern Saudi state we have never engaged
in such behavior and they will never
engage this is an aberration this is a
mistake this is a criminal act and those
responsible for it will be punished he's
acting like they need an investigation
because they don't know what's going on
it's so confusing it was a madhouse we
have no idea and then he goes back to
like version 3 or 4 of the story which
was some version of like we have no idea
who did anything but of course there's a
picture of a guy from the crown prince's
security detail and he says oh that's
nothing you don't need to worry about
that so the original question did the
crown prince know anything about it if
there were people closely tied to him
involved in this operation
there weren't people closely tied to him
were involved in this operation there
were pictures of some security officers
who may have been part of his security
detail from time to time but this is
normal security people who deal in
security details rotate among different
officials both domestic and foreign so
having somebody in a picture does not
imply that they're closed at all if a
regular Trump Secret Service agent were
in a picture where someone had been
tortured killed and dismembered which
the government initially claims to know
nothing about and then gave five
different stories regarding would we
believe that that's true I don't think
so and then here's the cherry on top
once again the use of this word rogue
again the conference is denied the
circumference is not aware of this even
the senior leadership of our
intelligence service was not aware of
this this was an operation that was a
rogue operation this was an operation
where individuals ended up exceeding the
authorities and responsibilities they
had it was all rogue could have been
anybody and meanwhile we found out this
morning thanks to CNN's reporting that a
body double was used that looked sort of
like Khashoggi to create a fake
surveillance trail one person and we're
putting the picture up for our audience
you'll notice the real Khashoggi on the
left and this sort of fake Ashoke on the
right a member of the 15 man team
suspected in the death of Jamaal
khashoggi dressed up in the clothes
khashoggi was wearing when he went to
the embassy put on a fake beard and then
deliberately placed himself in front of
security cameras Pat it's totally normal
to show up to interrogations with a team
that brings a bone saw a body double and
fake beards because a fight might break
out where a 59 year old tries to fight
15 people and ends up taken apart that
body double that looked pretty good
though pretty convincing you just got to
lower the frames per second on the
surveillance footage yeah he was i I
believe that that was him for sure this
is a full-on conspiracy folks I want to
hear from you about it I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on Twitter a David
Pakman show I am thrilled to tell you
that today's episode is sponsored in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka
is a really unique service for your
phone tablet and web browser and it is
incredibly useful for people like me who
love books and
but are busy blinka stakes the best and
most popular non-fiction books and
condenses them into 15-minute audiobooks
I'm sure that if you're like me you have
a very long list of books that you've
been meaning to read you only have so
many hours in the day and that's why
blink astiz so amazing they take the
most important information the themes
the insights from each book and they
distill it into a 15 minute audio book
that you can listen to in one sitting
I've listened to a ton of books on blink
'us
our audience can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube
I've put a link in the description I
have listened to blinka spokes about
economics about political science about
history about science so many
interesting things and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink accom slash Pakman that's bli
nki st.com
/p a que ma n